استضيف اليوم محمد نزار يعيش وزير الماليه
السابق في الجمهوريه التونسيه للحديث عن
العالم ومن طاقتنا اليوم وما يهزهما من
ازمات الاقتصاديه وبيئيه واجتماعيه
الوزير يعيش من الشخصيات النادره التي
حظيت باحترام التونسيين في السنوات
الاخيره والتي حكمت الاحداث هناك بان
ينسحب من المسؤوليه السياسيه وان يتوقف
برنامجه الذي انطلق فيه للاصلاح
تخرجك مهندس اقتصاد من المدرسه المركزيه
بتاريس وكذلك منها خبره واسعه في المجالات
الاستراتيجيه والاقتصاديه والماليه
والتكنولوجيا الحديثه وعمل في العديد من
دول العالم وله معرفه كبيره بالدول
العربيه حيث عاش واشتغل في غالبيه الدول
العربيه
احييكم اينما كنتم من العربيه انا منتهى
روحي وهذا البعد الاخر
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد زياده غير مسبوقه في بؤر
التوتر والنزاعات والاحتباس الحراري
تتضاعف معها بنسق المجنون
او اللاجئين يكونون قد بلغوا نقاط دخول
دول غير دول اما فرارا من حرب او بحثا عن
لقمه عيش او هروبا من منطقه التوتر
النزاعات متعدده العوامل تجبر ملايين
الاشخاص على النزوح من افغانستان مرورا
الى القرن الافريقي
الساحل الافريقي مثلا يفر حاليا منها
الالاف بسبب نزاعات الطابع ارهابي احيانا
او بسبب المناخ او عدم المساواه واذا كان
ملايين الباكستانيين ما زالوا يعانون من
فيضانات مدمره في بلد اصبحت فيه تداعياته
الاحترار محسوسه ما زال الدول شمال
افريقيا في انتظار بضعه مليمترات من
الامطار رغم رثاء بدا يستعد للرحيل وفي
افغانستان تهدد المجاعه ما يقرب من ثلاثه
وعشرين مليون نسمه وتحرم ملايين الفتيات
من مقاعد الدراسه وفي الصومال يواجه
حوالين 213 الف شخص خطر الموت الوشيك بسبب
المجاعه والجفاف اما السودان فتتزايد
حاجته للمساعده وهو الذي يستضيف اكبر عدد
من النازحين في القاره الافريقيه
ويوميا هناك مئات من اللاجئين يغادرون
اوكرانيا بعد ان وصل نحو ثمانيه ملايين من
مواطن اوكرانيا الى الاراضي الاوروبيه
مقارنه ب 1.3 مليون في ذروه الازمه في
سوريا في عام 2016 سوريا التي انضافت الى
مشالها ازمات صحيه في الاونه الاخيره
وروما مرور شهور طويله على حرب اوكرانيا
الا ان العالم ما زال يعاني من شحال
الامدادات
وتضاف يوميا جحاف من العاطلين وتفلت اعمال
بل ان لائحه الدول التي اصبحت تحتاج لقروض
عاجله ضخمه من مؤسسات التمويل الدوليه
اصبحت طول يوما اثر يوم وبعض منها يقع في
قلب المنطقه العربيه
يسعدني ان ارحب للحديث في هذا الموضوع
بضيفي من تونس سعاده الوزير محمد نزار
يعيش اهلا بك معنا
اهلا بك معالي الوزير يعني
وجهه نظرك في ما يشهده العالم اليوم كيف
يمكن وصفه الى اي مدى ينبغي علينا ان نعيش
مع بعض الوضع
حسب راينا التوصيف يمكننا ان يكون الا
صعبه من ناحيه العالميه هناك
[موسيقى]
في سعر العديد من المواد من الاوليه
والاساسيه والنفط وغير ذلك
كان له تاثير كبير على القدره الشرائيه
وعلى التضخم في العديد من الدول
تقريبا
في السنوات الاخيره يعني العدد الجملي
اصبحنا تقريبا في 650 مليون شخص
تحت الخط الفقر همم وهذا بالاضافه بالطبع
الى مخاوف كبيره من ناحيه النمو في العديد
من الدول خاصه من الدول الكبيره ممكن
النقود وممكن حتى انكماش الانقسام همم
اقتصادي وهذا سيؤثر طبعا على بقيه دول همم
العالم هذا كله طبعا انضاف الى السياسات
الاقتصاديه المعتمده حاليا لو خاصه سياسيه
النقديه وارتفاع النسبه المديريه في
العديد من البنوك المركزيه في العالم التي
ستؤثر سلبا على النمو الاقتصادي يعني
ارتفاع نسبه المديريه ستؤثر سلبيا على
النمو الاقتصاديه في المجال القصير
على المستوى العالمي
هي صراحه
يعني الانظمه الموديلات القديمه الموجوده
الهاتف المحليه ولكنها تداعيات كبرى لها
ثديها كبرى على الشرائح الضعيفه اولا
لانها تدفع في اسعار اكبر الغذاء والتنقل
وما الى ذلك تدفع اكثر همم النساء يعني
النقديه والقروض
وليست من ميزانيه همم كبيره وانت فعلا
الفائده سيظهر هذه الشرائح لما نظهر على
ال- ال- نسبه التضخم واحتمال الناس التضخم
بالارتفاع بالنسبه
لبعض الشرائح هي لا تساعد وكذلك كل
الاقتصاديين تقريبا وخاصه للدراسات
القديمه بما في ذلك يعني هناك همم اصحاب
همم
قالوا اللي همم ال- ال- الزياده في النسبه
المديريه سوف تؤثر سلبا على همم على همم
على المستوى الاقتصادي في المستوى القريب
والمتوسط لان الشركات طبعا يعني يهتم
التكلفه اكبر سوف تست- ال- الاشخاص
يستاهلها يكون اقل انتاج سوف ينقص
الاستثمار سوف ينقص التشغيل سوف ينقص
القدره الشرائيه
لازم الحذر وكل الحظر من هذه السياسات
وراينا حتى في لما طبق وهذه السياسات
التاثير على نسبه نسبه التضخم لم تكن كانت
اقل من المرج همم ذلك كل الحظر من هذه
الاليات الخطيره الخطيره جدا والتي اثرت
سلمى وخاصه على الشرائح ضعيفه هل هناك اي
تشابه تراه بين هذه الازمه التي يعيشها
العالم حاليا مع ازماته السابقه امام هذه
المره فعلا هو في تدخل همم غير حذر في
السياسات النقديه العالميه يؤدي الى تعقيد
الوضع اكثر من الازمات السابقه التي مرت
على العالم
هي ظاهريا ازمه تشبه كثير الازمات السابقه
مثلا ازمه 2008 و2 2011 يعني خاصه على
الارتفاع بعض الاسعار المولد الاوليه
والمده والحجم قبلك ولكن التحليل الاعمق
يقول ان هذه الازمه مختلفه كثيرا على
سابقاتها هذه ليست بازمه ماليه هذه ليست
بازمه همم
عرض على بعض المواد همم وليس غيرها
وكذلك همم المناخ كله السياق كل هذه
الاسماء المختلفه جدا يعني بعد الكفيل الى
حد
والحرب في في اوكرانيا
وتداعياتها الارتفاع الاسعار ابتداء من
قبل الحرب في همم في في في اوكرانيا شوفنا
كذلك العديد من الدول والمديونيه لعديد من
الدول ارتفعت باسم كبيره
وتدخل فيه دوامات همم اخرى ثانيه نطاق
العالمي كله كازمه مختلفه السياق مختلف
وكذلك حتى النظام
معالي الوزير بانه جذور الازمه همم لا
علاقه لها كثيرا بالنظام المالي العالمي
اا وان الحروب والازمات الصحيه كبد نايتين
وما زلنا نعاني منه حتى الان همم كان له
التاثير الاكبر يعني الامر يتعلق بمشكله
هيكليه في النظام المالي والاقتصاد
العالمي لعدم القدره على مواجهه هذه
المصائب او الكوارث
هي الازمات الحاليه حسب راينا كشفت
العديد من النقائس
والحدود النظام الاقتصادي والمالي العالمي
كنا نعرف ولم ناخذ كل الدروس من ازمه 2008
للاسف والان اصبحنا في نهايه حصرنا نهايه
مرحله كانه قوس كبير ابتداء تقريبا من 300
سنه والان نحن في في مرحله تغيير هذا
النظام يعني توازنات كبيره جديده في
العالم ونظام جديد ولابد ان يكون هناك
نظام جديد في اكثر عداله واكثر مساواه
يعني
تقريبا فما عشرات الاشخاص في العالم
يمتلكون مثل ما يمتلك نصف سكان
همم على الوزير يعني كيف ممكن حل هذه
المشكله كيف الطريقه الانقاذ او المعالجه
كيف ممكن خلق نظام عالمي جديد من المسؤول
هو النظام اصلا
هذا النظام ابتدا منذ عقود عشرات السنوات
اللي ما ننظر للتاريخ ونعتبر من التاريخ
وخاصه في الحرب العالميه الثانيه واتفقات
بريطاني ثم الخروج من هذه الاتفاقيات في
السبعينات في اوائل السبعينات وماذا صار
للدولار ولا قطع صله بالذهب
قيمه وكنابلغ وكميه كذلك ثم
في هذا في هذا النظام المالي العالمي
ووراءه كانت العديد من الافكار الايجابيه
صراحه يعني
تفعل الاستثمار
تشغيل المردوديه وما الى ذلك فهذا كله
ولكن اللي شفناها ان هناك انحياز
واصبحتاليه مشطه واثرت كثيرا على عديد من
الشرائح بما في ذلك الدول المتقدمه
الملايين واغلبيه الشرع المتوسطه
ما هي الحلول هناك حلول
العمليه والهدف الاول لاننا نكون عندنا
قراءه سليمه سليمه لما صار في الازمات وفي
النظام عندنا قراءه استشرافيه لماذا
سيصيبه هناك رهانات كبيره في العالم كبيره
جدا يعني جاي وهو لازم مجلس تحت معناها
على في نفس الطاوله الدول الكبرى وجميع
الدول والمنظمات الكبيره
والبنك الدولي والصندوق النقد الدولي
والكثير منها والبنوك العالميه
همم
الميزانيات طبعا الدول التي تم يعني
اقراها في البرنامج يعني في سنه 2003
ميزانيات اللي همم التي جهز للاسلحه
الدفاع عن شفنا ارقام همم لا مثيل لها
التحديات التكنولوجيا وكل هذه التحديات
معك سعاده الوزير ولكن
عامه وحلول عالميه همم نحن متفقين على ان
لا استطيع لا تعني لا اريد او انني استطيع
الاستطاعه هي مع الاراده لكن ما تتفضل به
لانه الازمه عالميه هل يمكن ان تكون
الحلول فرديه بمعنى دوله ما تحاول ان تحل
المشاكلها بالاقتراحات التي يمكن ان تقدم
دون ان يكون هناك شراكه عالميه في حال هذه
الازمه كونها عالميه اما انه يجب ان تحل-
يحل الموضوع جذريا على مستوى العالم
طيب للاجابه لسؤال اختي الكريمه هناك
خمسه تحديات الكبر وسوف ترين الى الخمسه
لابد من حلول عالميه وليس حلول
تقريبا نصف سكان البشريه في سنه 2030 سوف
تعيش في تحت نقص كبير في المياه
سوف نصل تقريبا 800 مليار دولار استمارات
جديد تقريبا خمسه مليون دولار هل يمكن في
هذه الفراغات الكبيره الى حدود لها
وطريقه مراقبتها وقوانينها و و و و الى
ذلك الكلام يمكن ان تحل بطريقه فرديه هل
التغيرات الديمقرارات الديموغرافيه الكبرى
مثلا الكبرى كبيره جدا يعني العديد من
الدول المهم معدل الاعمار في سنه 2050
ممكن 55 سنه في العديد من الدول الكبرى
المتطوره
ولكن وفي نفس الوقت في افريقيا في نفس
الفتره ممكن نصل الى اثنين مليار تقريبا
300 مليارات يعني ومعدل الاعمار اكثر شويه
من 20 سنه سيكون كبير
واضيف الى ذلك هو كان نسبه تباعيه لشراء
اهل المتقدمه في الصين يعني اكثر من 65
سنه سوف تتجاوز 50% في اغلبيه الدول
الكبرى وقد تصل الى 70 و75
ربما تكون اكثر واقعيه وبعيده عن النظريه
في ما يتعلق بمحاولات انقاذ هذا العالم
سنتابع اكثر في هذا الموضوع همم علي همم
السيد محمد نزار يعيش ارجو ان تبقى معي
سنذهب الى فاصل قصير نعود بعده لمتابعه
الحوار في البعد الاخر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم معنا من جديد ونتابع مع معالي
وزير الماليه التونسيه الاسبق السيد محمد
نزار يعيش في الحديث عن ازمات العالم واذا
كان هناك في رؤيا للخروج منها نتحدث عن
ازمات الاقتصاديه المناخيه الديموغرافيه
الاجتماعيه وكلها ومره اخرى ارحب بك معنا
معالي الوزير والمتحدث مره اخرى عن اهم
الريانات
المستقبليه العالميه الكبرى اللي بتشوفها
اي رهان ينبغي ان يحظى بالاولويه في
المعالجه نحن هنا يعني لا نتحدث في علم
الفلك يعني بمعنى انه ابراج ونتوقع ان
يحصل كذا وكذا كله بناء على معلومات بناء
على همم مقياس من الذي يتوقعه في السنوات
القليله القادمه طرق معالجه كيف ممكن تكون
الطرق اول حاجه هذه الرهانات ليست حجميه
وهي مربوطه جدا كذلك
بمدى تفاعل الفاعلين واصحاب القرار ويمكن
تغيير من تغيير من وضع هذه
الرهانات حسب القدره ولكن الذين اراها
اليوم ولو
المستوى المناخي
والملاحظ ان خصصنا تقريبا عشرات يعني
الدولارات
لهذا الريال ولكن العديد من المواصفات
وحقيقه تعديل الطريق الذين سيروا فيه همم
والحاجه الثانيه ان هذه الرهانات لا يمكن
النظر اليها كريه هناك
يعني متشابهه وتاتي فيه في حاله كذلك ازمه
وصفناها في الاسئله
همم ولكن
التشابك هذه الرهانات تؤدي الى معناها
مبيعات تكون اكبر واسرع على البشريه كامله
للرجوعلك انا حسب راينا هناك بعض من
الناحيه المبدايه لازم تصليح بعض المفاهيم
ثم عمليا هناك تقريبا ثلاثه او اربع محاور
ممكن نشتغل همم
هذه الازمه اصبحت يعني عندها تكاليف كبرى
وما تكاليف مخفيه على العالم كله وانه
تاخير التاخير في الحلول سيكلفنا اكثر
وسيكل ابناءنا اكثر مصاريف واكثر تكاليف
ياسمين
العادي للثوره
وظائف معروفه اربعه وخمسه وظائف كوبرا هو
الوسيله واعداد ولا يمكن ان يكون هو الهدف
الهدف خلق ثروه والانتاج والتوزيع الانتاج
والمردوديه وما الى ذلك الحاجه الاخرى
الذي يجب اصلاح كذلك كل هذه ال ال ال ال
ال ال الاموال التي البعيده والغير
المراقبه
والتكاليف المخفيه هناك العديد من
التكاليف المعرفيه التي لامها تحدث عليها
في في مواضيعنا مثل همم وممكن ياخذ
مثاليهم المثال الاول هو المناخير المثال
المناخي لماذا وصلنا لهذه الحاله لانه
لمده سنوات وعقود هناك البعض وفي بعض
المناطق لو يسوون هناك تكلفه على المناخ
ولم ناخذ بعين الاعتبار هذه التكلفه في في
همم في في كل فتره الانتاج في البيع و
لماذا نتحملوها جميعا لانه هناك لم نكن
نقدم ذلك وتكلف مخفيه اخرى ممكن
زياده في في النسب المديريه العديد من ال-
للبنوك الكبرى المركزيه هي لها تاثير
مباشر على الميزانيات وعلى مديونيات همم
الديون العديد من الدول ذات الاقتصاديه
المتوسطه وضعيفه هذه كلها اشياء مخفيه يجب
حسابه القراءات الحسابات الحساب لها ويجب
دراستها ويجب وضعها على الطاوله للمزيد من
العدل هذا هو المطلوب صحيح
معالي الوزير ممكن اتباعها في الدول
العربيه اخذين بعين الاعتبار كل هذه
التغيرات يعني على المستوى الفردي دوله
دوله لا تستطيع ولكن هل على المستوى
الجمعي في الدول العربيه يمكن يكون في
سياسات يمكن اخذهها
نعم بالطبعا في المستوى عالارض العربيه في
الدول العربيه بالطبع او شيء يجب علينا ان
ناخذ بعض الدروس من الماضي ونعرف انه حتى
تحليل الازمات الحاليه لازم تقريبا يعني
80% من الثروه التي خلقت في 30 سنه اللي
فاتت كانت مربوطه بنسبه الاستثمار
والابتكار خاصه الابتكار والابداع كم كان
همم العرب بالنسبه هناك تقريبا 1000 مليار
دولار استثمارات في الابتكار سنويا ما هي
نسبته همم
ترقيم معاهدنا همم مقارنه بين معهد القدره
الدول التي نجحت والدول التي خلقت اكثر
ثروها ولا الدول التي اشتهرت
لهذه الازمات بطريقه اسهل وقارن للاضرار
هي الدول التي عرفت الدول التي بنت مؤسسات
وانظمه وقواعد وقوانين قويه وهذا المطلوب
وهذه المطلوب هذا هو المطلوب الوحده
العربيه وليس ككلام الصادق كلام يعني
مصطلح قديم ومصطلح صعب يعني قراءه للتاريخ
واشوف مما قالت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه منظمين اكثر من 200 سنه شوفوا
الاتحاد الاوروبي خاصه في الحرب بعد الحرب
والدماء الثانيه والدماء لم تجف وقرروا
بناء شيء كبير
وعمله
هو مش ضروري يكون في وحده سياسيه لان تعرف
الاراء كلها بتختلف لكن على الاقل التعاون
الاقتصادي في المصلحه العامه للجميع همم
النظره البعيده البعيده نظر البعيد بعد 30
40 سنه يمكن النص لها قبل هي همم
نذهب الى مرحله المؤسسات والقوانين
والمؤسسات العربيات والتي تكون مجدره او
شبه مجدره على الجميع وهي هذه نظره
الشخصيه وهذه نظره البعيده تعرف انها
صعيبه صعب الان ولكن على الاقل خلينا نقدم
فيها لما تكون عنها رهانات كبيره للتحدث
عليها ولما انه المؤسس حقيقه هذه الان نعم
العربيه المشتركه سوف نرسل رساله قويه
للعالم بطبعه هي رساله دائما لازم تكون
ايجابيه وتعاون ولكن على الاقل ما فيها
اكثر مديه مع النظام المالي العالمي مع
المنصات الكبرى مع الميتاديرس مع ال- ال-
القوه الاقتصاديه الكبرى المشكله وين
المشكله في هذه الفكره
الرئيسيه حصريا هي مشكله مفهوم قديم
للسياده ما هو مفهوم السياده لانه القرار
لان المر الى مؤسسات والى قوانين تجمعنا
نحن العرب هي هي همم مبنيه على مفهوم قديم
السياده ولكن ما هو السياده واين هي
السياده لما تكون مثلا السياده الاقتصاديه
لما جميعا نسبه كبيره من من من
ريده
اين هي السياده الماليه لما ما نملكه
بالعمله الصعبه وحتى الدهون وقريره
في الخارج حاسس بس هي سيادتها الاقتصاديه
لها الحق في ذلك ولكن نحن اا نحن من ما ما
ما ما ما ما له تاثير عليه
واين هو كذلك واين هي السياده الفكريه لما
انا وانت وابنائنا همم نقذي العديد من
الوقت الكبير في هذه المنصات
التواصل الاجتماعي
خبر من يتحكم فيها ويقررون ما يبعثون من
ماده
ولحدنا دخول بعض الافكار الغريبه في
مجتمعاتنا ولحد حتى في بعض الديمقراطيه
الكبرى هناك تاثير على على الانتخابات
فهذه مفهوم السياده لازم يتطور مع
الرهانات مع الدروس في الخارج
حسب
وليس هناك طريق الا بالوحده الفعليه والتي
لا تكون مربوطه ببعض الارادات لبعض
القيادات ولكنها تكون ملزمه ملزمه للجميع
وصدقوني اذا كان وصلنا للمرحله هذه احنا
وابناءنا او ابناءنا سنكون قطعنا شوقا
كبيرا وخدام لها وخدمه كبيره
لهذه الامواج التي تاتي من حولنا تبدا
استغل الفرصه وجودك معنا معالي الوزير
واسالك عن الوضع التونسي همم كيف بتشوفوا
حاليا هل هل
التونسيين اللي بتساءلوا هالمزال امل يمكن
ان نعطيهم املا في المستقبل في تونس
لازم يكون مربوط بما صار بعد ثوره قبل
الثوره التونسيه 12 سنه تونس الان في فتره
بناء الديمقراطي ديمقرايتها الطريقه التي
ولها تكاليف بطبعها ومصاريف وطريق البناء
الديمقراطي لا ليس بالطريقه
المستوى همم
اجمالا لما نحلل على مستوى السنوات
والعشرات السنوات ان شاء الله احنا في
طريق همم الصحيح وفي تونس هناك طبقه من
اعلى راس من اعلى تراس من في جميع
المجالات في جميع المجلات
والتكنولوجيا والتعليم
والعديد من المجالات وهذه الطبقه
خاصه في الثانويه
دراسات خارجيه تقول انه هناك ضغوطات على
الماليه العموميه وضغوطات في السيوله
ومشاكل الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وهذا لا
يمكن الانكار ولكن الامل لما بلد عنده هذه
المبادئ وعنده هذه النخبه وعنده هذا
الشباب ما شاء الله في تونس وبره من تونس
وانا بعرف منهم الكثير همم عن هذه
الخيرات البشريه وهي القيام انا باذن الله
تعالى على على تونس والامل موجود
بقوه ان شاء الله اتمنى ان تونس بطبعها
تكون فيها على الاقل خلافه يعني همم تكون
منصه جهويه كبيره همم يعني همم في الصحه
وفي التعليم وفي همم في في الماليه اتمنى
ان يكون ان تستثمر اكثر في خيراتها
وتاريخها وحضرتها في فرحتها وفي الفلاحه
وفي سياحه وغيرها في المعادي همم
التاريخيه الكبيره اللي عندها
واتمنى له همم تون والقطه كذلك
التكنولوجيا العراقي في مجال القبائل في
مجال الصناعي وتكون رائده في هذا المجال
واتمنى كذلك ان تونس ان شاء الله تكون هي
اكثر من بوابه انها منصه منصه لافريقيا
بحكم القرابه
الافريقيه بحكم يعني الجغرافيه والقرابه
الثقافيه وبحكم التكلفه بحكم كذلك رجال
الاعمال التونسيين بالاسواق الافريقيه
واللي ممكن تساعد الدول العربيه الاخرى
والدول الاوروبيه في هذه بعض التصور
تمنح الفرصه لكل هذه العقليات المتطوره
والمتعلمين في تونس من اجل ان يكون الاداء
واضح لا ان يكون الخلاف السياسي سببا في
ازاحه من يعلم لصالح من لا يعلم شكرا
جزيلا لك على المشاركه معنا معالي الوزير
محمد نزار يعيش وزير الماليه التونسي
الساب شكرا جزيلا
الى هنا انتهت حلقه اليوم من البعد الاخر
يمكنكم دائما متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك ويوتيوب كما
يمكنكم الاستماع الى حلقتنا على العربيه
بركان
[موسيقى]